[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right
the walkable
and laura
and laura as as predicted straight over
to the crowd now i'm not entirely
certain that we have a microphone close
enough to try and pick up on what is
being said indeed it looks
uh pretty much like the security is is
flanking the king at both sides and
indeed behind keeping a very very close
eye on what's going on david you you
will have seen you will have seen close
protection work like this a number of
times the close protection team from the
police service of northern ireland would
have taken over the moment his royal
highness and her majesty landed at
george belfast city airport they are now
providing their security as they
shake hands and chat to some of the
young people who have gathered here to
welcome the king on his first visit we
knew they were just moments away for two
reasons some police officers on either
side of the
hillsborough castle take up their
position and we can also see some staff
from the royal palaces also in position
ready to lower the union flag completely
it currently flies of half-mast and the
moment
the king arrives it will be replaced by
the royal standard at full mast so that
will be just a few moments away the king
has arrived a little late in northern
ireland but he's no hurry it would seem
taking time to chat to people here in
hillsborough and these moments very
important for the new monarch face to
faith with his people
face to face for the first time as their
king
and we heard as he stepped out of the
car the cheers god saved the king god
saved the king the crowd chanted
and the noise
as he approached the crowd was quite
something and there we have people
holding flowers
waving flags
greeting the king
[Music]
and it's thought he may well come and
look at some of the flowers that have
been laid outside the gates of the
castle here too
huge mound of those
bunches of flowers that people have been
laying over the last couple of days
well as we keep watching these pictures
lots of beaming faces plenty of school
kids and indeed a couple of older ladies
uh along to say hello to their new king
but let's bring in someone
someone who knows a thing or two about
the royal family uh john brewton former
taoiseach of course and former
ambassador of the european union to the
united states mr briton great to have
you on the programme today i i wonder
your thoughts when you heard the news of
the passing of her majesty queen
elizabeth ii
well i think it's fair to say that the
united kingdom has lost a great servant
in her manchester the queen
she was somebody who put her duty to her
country her duty to other people before
her own personal convenience
and she lived her entire life for her
country and i think that's something
whatever views one might have about
issues between britain and ireland
people in ireland admired very greatly
and admired her particularly for her
visit to ireland in
2012 which did so much to build
reconciliation between britain and
ireland
we'll speak a little bit more if you can
mr bruton about about the relationship
between the republic and at the united
kingdom the relationship that the queen
did try to foster we were speaking this
this morning with my colleagues david uh
david
has been pointing out the fact that we
david blevins pointing out the fact that
you know we charles has been a regular
visitor himself to the republic at the
queen also having a fondness for a very
very strong fondness for the country
yes indeed when he was prince of wales
he came to ireland in 1995 i was a
teacher
in ireland at the time and i
showed him around in different places in
ireland and it was quite clear then that
he
personally has a deep interest in both
parts of this country in fact he's
already visited the majority of the 32
counties of the island of ireland and i
believe it is
one of his ambitions to visit the
remaining ones and as soon as he can
he's very interested and i think he is a
unifying figure among irish people in
the sense that he's highly regarded in
in the republic of ireland uh but also
as as you can see very highly regarded
in northern ireland now obviously there
are divides in northern ireland where
part of the community in northern
ireland doesn't have quite the same
attitude towards the union jackfridge
for example as people on the unionist
side of the divide in northern ireland
have
and one must acknowledge that in many
respects while
we have had a political agreement in the
good friday agreement to on a basis for
governing northern ireland jointly
between the two communities there hasn't
been a reconciliation on the ground
between the two communities and indeed
some recent opinion paul dallas suggests
that the divisions have become even
deeper that
as many as 70 percent of the nationalist
community
believe that the ira campaign of
violence over 30 years was justified
whereas at the time most nationalists
did not believe it was justified and
quite an intransitive position is being
taken as well
on
the requirement to scrap the protocol
for the democratic unionist party to
enter the um the re-enter the strawman's
agreement uh institutions
so there is quite a deep level of
polarization
in northern ireland but i think um the
king
personally uh can help create an
atmosphere in which reconciliation
becomes more possible but i think what's
vital is that the two governments the
irish and british governments
start working together
on finding solutions to the remaining
difficulties in many ways
intergovernmental relations between
britain and ireland are much much worse
now than they were when the queen visits
in 2012 and that needs to be repaired by
the two governments and hopefully the
new prime minister in the united kingdom
will give this a priority because
ireland
is her only
european union neighbor with which
britain has a land boundary and that
needs to be
acknowledged
um mr putin there have been a number of
moments of significance and and
apologies if you just mentioned that
they all do the sound quality here at
hillsborough i hope you understand this
it is pretty poor given the enthusiasm
that has been for the arrival of the
king um but i wonder if you might just
speak specifically about that handshake
that took place between her majesty the
queen and martin mcginnison and how that
was viewed in the republic
well i think people in the republic at
that time felt this was a very
difficult and brave thing for the queen
to do bearing in mind that the ira
with which martin mcguinness was
associated had assassinated george
mountbatten
uh lord mountbatten who in many ways was
like a godfather to the new king
and a very close personal connection
existed between the mount franklin
and the royal family and the fact that
he was murdered by the ira and yet her
majesty the queen was happy to shake
hands with martin mcguinness who at that
time was on a path towards peace and a
path away from the violence that he had
previously espoused that was in human
terms an immensely
brave and difficult thing that the queen
did and i think it was acknowledged on
this side of the border in particular
how what an effort that was on her part
and how much appreciated it was
mr britain i'm afraid we'll have to
leave it there but thank you so much for
your time and as you can see on your
screen at the moment whilst uh the new
king greets his subjects we wait for the
royal standard to fly above uh
hillsborough castle itself huge crowd
here from my position in the kind of the
media gantry and must be a couple of
hundred people most of whom apparently
have their their mobile phones out
recording the moment for personality so
i suspect if you spend any amount of
time on social media in the next couple
of hours you may find plenty of
closer shots and even perhaps a few
words from the new king and his queen
consort
you can probably also make
just the level of security that there is
here commented on already of course by
david blevins
but understandably so still tensions
in this community
and of course in just a second we expect
once the king has finished uh greeting
those that gathered here at hillsborough
castle that he will as he has done uh
the other locations that he has traveled
to
take a quick walk have a look at the
flowers have a look at some of the
testimonies have a look at some of the
comments that have been left by by
members of the public i have to say i've
seen a few floral arrangements over the
past few days that the way in which the
staff here at hillsborough castle have
perhaps organized the bouquets have laid
it out next to those
those golden boss gates uh around
surrounding the castle itself
is quite stunning quite staggering in
fact um
a lot of bundik
as we watch now
what do you think is going through the
king's head
these are official functions we have to
remember this this is this is a duty of
a duty of the king yeah but he is in a
period of warning he is in black and the
applause just spontaneously breaking out
i think this applause says it all and
you could see
looking at him greeting the crowd there
was a mixture of thank you as obviously
the crowds paid tribute to the queen but
also smiles as well as they welcomed him
as their king as well and i think that
is the absolute mix of emotion for him
at the moment really it is a a double
moment really but certainly the crowds
here and they will be able to smell
those smiles i can we can smell them
here can't we the power of the smell
will be amazing and it will
it will mean a lot i think looking at
them laid out like this i don't notice
any marmalade sandwiches though so i
think the message might have got through
there's no sandwiches they were taking
flowers from the crowd here as well so
many i noticed one
one member of their party couldn't carry
any more and had to walk off and leave
them while she also deposited the
flowers in this pile here but they will
be looking at those messages and and
remembering the queen and inside once
they're inside the castle and the royal
standard there is the poise you can see
it fluttering just above that chimney
press where it'll be raised as soon as
he walks through those gates they will
see the photos of that exhibition they
will look back at
the years of the queen and the time she
spent here in northern ireland
david just just remind us david who will
uh uh who will the king be meeting
inside hillsborough castle today who
would the king be meeting in second
quarter uh just as he enters through the
gates i hear shouts have long lived the
king
and the royal standard is raised above
hillsborough castle in county dying the
official residence
of the king in northern ireland
a significant moment
prince charles as he was previously
having been here on 39 occasions his
40th visit to northern ireland happens
to be his first as monarch and as he
makes his way to the castle now with her
royal highness the queen consort they
will be preparing for a number of
meetings with political leaders from
northern ireland people like sir jeffrey
donaldson leader of the dup but most
notably with the first minister
designate of northern ireland michelle
o'neill is the deputy leader of sinn
fein she's first minister designate
because there is no functioning devolved
government at this time but it's hugely
significant and symbolic that she's come
here to offer her condolences as an
irish republican but she has often
stated that she wants to be a first
minister for all the people in northern
ireland and this is a visual
demonstration of that we we should we
should expect those the words that the
exchange to be pretty warm judging by
the comments that she's previously made
in the past few days in fact yes you
know how much things have changed in
northern ireland but you're here
and the irish republican pay tribute to
the queen and acknowledge that king
charles has now taken the throne and
extend her sympathy to her neighbors and
that we hear
the that is the gun salute that is the
gun salute how many of those are we
getting we're going to get 21 of those
the dog's not enjoying them perhaps as
much but it is the gun salute from the
grounds you can see the smoke from that
gun salute to the to the left of the
castle there but there'll be
six rounds a minute
21
21 rounds in total
it's a way it's a salute it's a gun
salute welcoming in the king and queen
console as they arrive at the castle the
royal standard now flying above the
castle and as they wait make their way
in there with the lord lieutenant
and other dignitaries inside as they say
looking at that exhibition spanning the
queen's 25 visits to northern ireland
from a princess back in 1945 right up
until 2016 which was the last time the
queen visited here with uh prince philip
when they went on the tour of the north
of northern ireland ending in the giant
supporting at the giant schools way
i'm sure you were there for david it was
quite the journey to
see the queen on that old steam train
make her way along the north coast the
scenic north coast which everyone comes
to northern ireland to visit of course
famous for the giants causeway among
other places of course for royal port
rush golf club these days where lots of
people come
to play a few rounds now that was a
significant visit in 2016 because not
only was the queen again taking the
opportunity to meet with the then first
minister and then deputy first minister
martin mcguinness and continue to give
her seal of approval in many ways to the
efforts that were going on to achieve
lasting peace in northern ireland it
would turn out to be her final visit to
northern ireland she was meant to come
last year for a very significant event
an ecumenical service to mark the
centenary of northern ireland but you
will recall a very short notice that she
had to cancel that trip because of ill
health people were very very keen that
she would come again and she court and
visit them sadly that was not to be the
case but as you've heard the welcome for
the new monarch today as he made his way
through the gates i heard shouts in the
background of long live the king so
certainly as far as the unionist
community is concerned
they're very very glad to be welcoming
his majesty to this corner of the united
kingdom
plenty of smiling faces as i take a
quick final look around the crowd
yeah the children seem particularly
pleased with the photos that they're
taking everyone's just peering over
their mobile phones at the moment
wondering whether or not they manage to
catch
the king in the back of their selfie
we're with the royal standard now flying
over hillsborough castle of the king has
arrived